SIB bugs life on the Baltic that's one
way to sum up the beetle sunshine tour
I'm meeting every summer of the world's
largest beetle fan community this year's
motto was crazy
not for sheeple a highlight was a rally
with different starting points
converging on one location the
fairgrounds by the travemünde a beach
this year a good 650 tuned and lovingly
designed VW's from three generations
came together a new record for the
Beatle sunshine tour
this woman admits this is a huge
community and everyone's a bit wacky the
wackier the funnier the motto says crazy
and that's why everybody looks the way
they do these girls from Berlin say they
have a shark alert they confirm it's a
great community they've been coming here
for years and enjoy it every time they
meet lots of people they know they say
the car is a cold besides it's fun
there's lots of room for creativity
a pirate saber can be a dipstick many
beetle owners give their imaginations
free rein when customizing their rides
among the star tuners is Sidney Hoffman
he's got an extremely creative with his
own beetle
he says anyone who knows him also knows
the beetle he's had since 2012 the RSI
before that and the bug before that he's
a beetle man many people might laugh and
ask what do you want with a beetle you
just have to drive one and you'll know
whether a Mini Mouse a little blue
monster or a Pokemon every beetle lover
is welcome here this young woman
explains that her beetle was originally
her everyday car she enjoys convertibles
riding low and loud but when that got
inconvenient for daily driving she
bought the beetle now she loves the
sense of community here everyone greets
her and smiles when she's driving around
the beetle brings people together and
hemispheres together in a very basic way
the beetle is ideally suited for
long-distance adventure gentlemen
recounts that he drove his beetle from
Shanghai to Hamburg ten years ago 15,000
kilometers without any trouble
he didn't even change the air filter he
drove through the sand and gravel of the
Gobi Desert with no problems at all
except one in Russia he had to fill up
on diesel the car only made it another
200 meters so he unscrewed the tap in
the fuel tank
let the 30 litres of diesel run out and
fill the back up with gasoline loves the
car because it holds so many memories
for him and his wife they've been
driving it for some 30 years and he puts
a lot of pleasure and love into his care
he doesn't need to drive fast he just
wants to enjoy the ride he drives for
the fun of it that's why he spent three
and a half months driving to China when
Tomball feel eisenach sheena tonight one
at a time
for some beetle owners the car is like a
family member
people in cars of different generations
even share certain features such as
these two green bugs this young man
describes their two cars as mother and
daughter they've named the 1962 model
Johanna and the 1998 model Louisa
insight they're almost identical the
same upholstery leather and even stretch
headliners they removed the center
consoles old parking brake levers and
brake calipers and put in new gear shift
levers for a real vintage look they only
finished the week before they repainted
and converted the body put on stone
guards and back and reupholstered the
seats all in all it took them about a
year to do the work so this is the
premiere this is the beetle sunshine
Tours 12th year Sidney Hoffman has
attended for several years now together
with rapper MC fitty he's got an
essential function to perform the beetle
walk is a kind of fashion show for the
most imaginative VW designs among them
is a hotrod worthy powerhouse and
graffiti on wheels and gaudy colors
and of course the green mother and
daughter are also on hand
the glorious climax is the premiere of
the New Beetle duan showroom floors next
year the bumpers colors and materials
are brand new this classic never seems
to grow old to some is simply the New
Beetle to others it's the stuff of
dreams and a source of inspiration for
entirely new and individual
customisations many of them will also be
swarming to next year's meet and travel
Munda on the Baltic